نتابع ايضا مره اخرى بعد الاعلام بانه يتم
تحضير الان للجوله الثانيه بعد اسبوعين
فيها الثامن والعشرين من شهر مايو الجاري
نذكر بان النسبه الاخيره التي يعني حسبت
حتى الان للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغاني
بلغت
49.51 قريبه جدا من خمسين بالمئه وهذا
يعطي ايضا تصورا عن المرحله المقبله كيف
ستسير الحمله الانتخابيه للرئيس التركي
وماذا يحتاج ليصل الى خمسين زائد واحد
للفوز في المرحله القادمه
44.88 وسنان اوغان والسؤال ما الذي سيفعله
ايضا سنان في المرحله المقبله 5.17 اذا
49.51 للرئيس التركي في النسبه العامه على
في الرئاسيات في تركيا
على الخريطه هذه الالوان كما ذكرنا في اول
لحظات البث امس قبل بدء اعلان النتائج ان
تلون هذه الخارطه مهم جدا للنظره لتركيا
على الصعيد التوزيع
النفوذ لكل تحالف والان انتهت الجوله
الاولى والجوله الثانيه ستكون على مستوى
تحالفين تحالف الشعب بقياده كمالك الجدار
اولو وتحالف الجمهور بقياده الرئيس التركي
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان وعند النظر الى
هذه الخريطه سيلاحظ عن ان الرئيس التركي
ايضا في الخارج لم يتمكن من حسم النتيجه
رغم حصوله على نسبه عاليه ب
57.19 وايضا كمال اجدار اوغلو قريب من
الاربعين في
39.85 وسنان اوران واحد فاصله تسعه
والسؤال هنا
المنسحب من السباق لن يكون له لم يكن له
تاثير في الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكن سنان
اوغن كان له تاثير وقد تنحى الرجلان في
المرحله الثالثه
وبالتالي ننتظر ما الذي سيفعله كمال وما
الذي سيفعله الرئيس التركي رجب ان نعود
الى الخريطه العامه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه معكم مشاهدينا اذا سمحتم شباب
ونتابع فيها بعض
بنظره عامه لماذا استطاع الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان على الاقل ان يحقق المركز
الاول في الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات
نعود الى الخزان الانتخابي للرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان على مدى كما واضح بحر
الاسود منطقه البحر الاسود لا نتحدث عنها
كثيرا لكنها هي اهم خزان انتخابي للرئيس
التركي بالاضافه الى الوسط وعندما نتحدث
كما ذكرنا اكثر من مره ان هناك سبع مناطق
تركيا اداريه تتوزع عليها كل الولايات 81
فان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان حسن
منطقه كامله لصالحه وهي منطقه البحر
الاسود ويتوقع ايضا ان تستمر هذه الامور
بالنسبه للرئيس التركي في الجوله التاليه
ما يحتاجه الرئيس التركي في الجوله
الثانيه هو ان ينظر الى المناطق التي
خسرها على منطقه البحر الابيض المتوسط
اكدان بالتركيه يعني منطقه البحر الابيض
المتوسط والتي خسر فيها هاتاي واضن
ومارسين وانطاليا وايضا بشكل مثير
للاهتمام في اللحظات الاخيره خسرت دينيزلي
خسر منطقه ديزل التي كان قد حصل عليها في
انتخابات 2018 رغم ان هذه الولايات
تاريخيا تعود الى حزب الشعب الجمهوري
وبالتالي كمالك له اولويه ساعدها الان
بالنسبه
المناطق التي ينبغي ان ينظر اليها الرئيس
التركي ايضا من الولايات هي اسطنبول
بطبيعه الحال التي خسرها بشكل مفاجئ
للكثيرين لكثير من المتابعين وان كان
بنسبه متقاربه مع كمالك الجدار اوغلو 46%.
لكمال اولو فارق ضئيل يعني 48.55
ماذا يحتاج الرئيس التركي في المرحله
المقبله التركيز ربما على اسطنبول
والسعادتها وهذا سيتطلب كثير من العمل
بالنسبه
لموظفي حزب العداله والتنميه تحديدا وهناك
كما يقال اشكاليه حصلت في حي واحد تسبب في
ازمه بالنسبه لاسطنبول وهي
حي اسكودار حي اسكودار حي تقليديا يعطي
اصواته في اسطنبول لحزب العداله والتنميه
خسره الان وهنا نبدا من خلال هذه الخريطه
نفهم ما الذي يحتاجه كل تحالف لاستعاده
بعض المناطق النفوذ كيف تتم استعاده
اسطنبول على الرئيس التركي ان ينظر بطبيعه
الحال الان سينظرون الى الاحياء التي
خسروها وكيف يمكن الاستعاده وسنفهم بعد
ذلك خارطه الحملات الانتخابيه كيف ستتم
قبل يعني خلال اسبوعين فقط يحتاج ان تكون
هناك حمله انتخابيه كبيره داخل اسطنبول في
المناطق التي خسرها ومنها اسكودار
باستعادتها لتحالف الجمهور انقر ايضا
خسرها الرئيس التركي بفارق ليس بالكبير
بنفس الطريقه تقريبا 47 و46 للرئيس التركي
47 كمالك والسؤال هنا ايضا ما الذي على
التحالف الجمهور لاستعادتها وما الذي
ينبغي بالمقابل على تحالف الشعب ان يعمله
للحفاظ على هذه المكتسبات والاضافه اليها
لانه واضح رغم حصوله على كل هذه الولايات
الرئيسيه ومنها انقره لم يتمكن
النتيجه لصالحه وهذا يعني يعطي كثير من
الاسئله حول فع عمل حزب الشعب الجمهوري
وايضا حزب ايبارتي حزب الجيد مرار اكشنر
كيف سيتعاملان مع هذه القضيه رغم دعم كبير
من المكون الكردي لم يتمكنوا مع حصولهم
على كل المدن والولايات الرئيسيه من حسم
النتيجه اذا انقره ينظر اليها باهميه من
قبل الرئيس التركي ولها رمزيه وكذلك
بالنسبه لكم
والسؤال ماذا سيفعل قد يكون مؤثرا وقد لا
يكون مؤثرا وهذا ربما يتم تراقبه والسؤال
عنه قال بانه لديه بعض الشروط سيتحدث
لمرشحي الرئاسه لكن متى
قد ترفض بطبيعه الحال من كمالك جدار اولو
لانه يطالبه بالتخلي عن المكون الكردي حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطيه او ما بات يعرف بحزب
اليسار الاخضر وهذا ما لا يمكن ان يقوم به
كمال بطبيعه الحال باعتبار ان 10% وكل هذه
المنطقه المدونه كانت بفضل المكون الكردي
ودعم دمرطاش زعيم حزب شعوب الديمقراطيه
سابقا حزب اليسار الاخضر وبالتالي لا يمكن
ان يستجاب الى دعوات سنان الذي يحصل ربما
يتم تجميد التعامل مع سنان وتعتبر ولا
يكون لديه افضليه في ولا يطلب منه الدعم
وبالعوده ايضا للخريطه العامه يمكن
مشاهدينا ان نتابع منطقه ايضا خسرها
الرئيس التركي وهي بالقصر وبالك قصير ايضا
بالاضافه الى مناطق في اقصى الشرق وهي
ارضها وقارس ايضا خسرها الرئيس التركي
ولدينا وهي منطقه ايضا كانت منطقه وحيده
لتحالف الجمهور وسط المكون الكردي ايضا
خاسرها الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في
ظل حفاظه على مناطق رئيسيه في منطقه ما
تعرف بالمناطق المتضرره من نتحدث عن
ملاطيا نتحدث عن غازي عن تاب تشانلي اورفا
وكيليس وايضا عثمانيه
ونتحدث ايضا عن كهرمان مارعش مركز الزلزال
كلها تم الحفاظ عليها بالنسبه للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان لكن نعود مره اخرى
ونقول ان سينان كان له تاثير ربما في
مناطق الاناضول حتى قونيا كان له تاثير
سنان اوان اين حصل على اعلى نسبه للتصويت
حصل على 11% في مسقط راسه هنا في منطقه
صغيره جدا باتجاه اذربيجان هي ايدر
وهي منطقه بسيطه وصغيره في الحجم كانت له
اصوات لحزب الحركه القوميه وهو يميني
شعبوي ايضا وسنان اوغان ينحدر من تلك
الولايه وحصل فيها على اعلى نسبه للتصويت
في عموم الجمهوريه التركيه باحدى عشر في
المئه
من المناطق التي خسرها الرئيس التركي
لصالح تحالف ايضا الشعب هي منطقه
اسكي شهير واسكي شهير هنا المحاذيه لانقره
تاريخيا في الاصل كانت تعطيه الاصوات لحزب
الشعب الجمهوري استطاع في الانتخابات
السابقه ان يحوزها الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لم يحافظ عليها في هذه الانتخابات
اذا ببساطه يمكن من خلال هذه الالوان نعرف
ان
كمالكي الاحمر الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان بالبرتقالي سيخوضاني جوله جديده
بعد اسبوعين سيتنافسان على هذه المناطق
مره اخرى من الصفر سنه تتحول الى البياض
وسيتم تلوينها مجددا كيف ستكون هذا نترقبه
وكيف ستكون الحملات الانتخابيه وهل سيدعم
سنان ايا من المرشحين في الجوله الاخيره